[Musique]
si notre amour pour les fruits et
légumes et éternels malheureusement ne
le sont pas qu'est ce qu'on a devant
nous un de ma vie bien on a des
emballages pour mieux conserver nos
fruits puis nos légumes à ma vie des
biens s'y connaît en conservation des
aliments
elle a d'ailleurs publié cette bible sur
le sujet est-ce qu'on a des chances
qu'il ya quelque chose dans ce qui
fonctionne oui oui
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il ya des
choses qui fonctionnent pour vrai qu'ils
sont prouvés par la science qui valent
beaucoup mieux en fait que ne rien faire
avec nos fruits et légumes
commençons par ceux contenant de
plastique donc dans cet emballage là il
ya des petites russie qui permet à la
respiration il faut garder en tête que
les fruits les légumes sont encore
vivants après que les écuries
donc ils vont continuer à respirer vont
prendre l'oxygène de l'air envoyé du gaz
carbonique et puis on a aussi la petite
grille ou fonds qui permet aux fruits
mais le principe général c'est quoi dans
celui ci on lit et mais dans un endroit
fermé c'est que ça va fermenter ça vous
pourrez donc permettre une respiration
du fruit puis éviter justement dépôt de
documents font la plupart de ces
contenants des glissières réglable
permettant de contrôler le passage de
l'air et des gaz
ces petites valves le sait c'est bon
mais c'est patricia tu fais je le mets
ici où je mets là j'ai pas l'impression
que ça change grand chose à mon nom soit
complètement fermée l'effectif nathan
pourrait tout simplement laissé deux
couvercles en trouvant un peu on aurait
aussi une ouverture
sinon nos soucis qui sont quand même
assez populaire les intérêts frais de
tupperware
au lieu d'avoir grillé comme ça mais on
a dit qu éviter si on veut qui permet de
récolter l'autre moi personnellement la
maison j'ai aucun de ces emballages le
donc j'ai tout simplement un plat à
lunch normale en polypropylène numéro 5
je mets un vin je sais qu'au fond puis
je laisse le couvercle du pain on
trouvait donc il ya moyen de faire
quelque chose à la maison le
tout aussi efficace en fait revenons au
top des pictogrammes nous invite à
conserver fruits et légumes selon une
certaine logique
les athées les frais taupe oreilles ont
classé les fruits en fonction de la
respiration donc l'idée c'est de mettre
ensemble les mêmes fruits et légumes qui
vont avoir le même taux de respiration
pour qui ensemble se nuisent pas ne
tiennent pas compte de l'éthylène qui
est dégagée par les fruits climatériques
donc les la figue ici par exemple sont
là mais avec la nana ça vous stresse et
la nana l'iqlim astérix de moulins
scientifique juste pour désigner tous
les fruits qui peuvent me rire après
quand les écueils
c'est là pendant de la tomate l'avocat
s'est des fruits sains qui peuvent
guérir après qu'on les a cueillies de
leurs plaindre on peut les laisser sur
le comptoir va ils vont devenir rouge
jaune donc ses fruits clinact erika sont
capables demeurer grâce au gaz éthylène
sahin hormones qui vont dégager notre
helmand donc si ça me permet d'avoir ce
super pouvoirs là mais ce gars et ils
doivent à stresser les autres fruits et
légumes qu'un fruit stressé veuille
venger comme nous ils vont récupérer
plus vite et va transpirer aussi donc la
respiration accéléré volet faire pour
république puis la transpiration voulait
faire perdre leur route donc ils vont
fêtera donc on veut vraiment séparer ces
deux catégories de fruits l'année pas
les mettre dans le même hall à free
pendant le même bac à légumes pas les
mettre dans le même contenant non plus
pour les entreposer pour éviter le
stress le de l'éthylène sur le marché il
existe d'ailleurs des capteurs
d'éthylène sous différentes formes
c'est du permanganate qui se trouve à
l'intérieur donc le but de ces petites
pomelos ça permet d'absorber le gaz
éthylène qui va déranger les autres
comme le brocoli le concombre tout seul
donc en l'absorbant on évite de les
stresser
placé dans le bac du frigo ou sur le
comptoir
il s'avère utile quand fruits et légumes
climatériques côtoient ceux qui ne le
sont pas ça fonctionne ça fonctionne
ouais ouais exactement ça ça fonctionne
super bien justement parce que ça fait
pas juste absorber les gaz en général
mais ça vaut vraiment ciblé l'éthylène
puis ça vole à la décomposer par contre
faut changer les petits sacs à
l'intérieur à peu près ou trois mois
d'autres marques
dès 4h au charbon mais à ma vie ne les
recommande pas mais jugeant moins
efficace autre catégorie de contenants
disponibles les sous vide
j'ai un doute ouais effectivement je
trouve ça quand même assez étrange les
sauver d'une technique et de
conservation l'étiquette intéressante
pour tout ce qui est aliments cuits mais
quand on parle d'aliments qui respire on
veut pas leur enlever l'horaire parce
qu'on va les faire fermenter dernière
catégorie les sacs de plastique
micro-perforé qui empêche l'air d'entrer
et retiennent l'humidité qui ont dit
petit trou à l'intérieur qui va
permettre aux fruits de respirer quand
même si vous n'en avez pas sous la main
vous pouvez utiliser des sacs à
congélation
en fait quelques trous puis on est ça qu
on peut m'utiliser qui va faire le même
travail
les fameux tiroirs dans le frigo leur
mission n'était elle pas justement de
conserver nos végétaux les bacs à
légumes sont possibles pas efficace pour
garder l'humidité qui est optimale
qu'inquiéter à trois corps donc le camp
et à trois quarts plein il ya assez de
fruits donc beaucoup d'absents permet
aux fruits aux légumes secs dans un
environnement quand même une idée potro
siècle car la clé de la conservation des
fruits et légumes et c'est justement
l'humidité un frigo c'est pas très
humide en général savent à peu près 60 %
d'humidité
c'est pas l'humidité idéal d'un légume
perdu par un manque 95 et 100 %
d'humidité donc plus d'humidité you le
plus 100 heureux donc si vous voulez
prolonger la durée de vie de vos fruits
et légumes conservés lait au frais dans
un milieu humide laisser l'air respiré
éviter de placer les végétaux
climatériques avec ceux qui ne le sont
pas
mais la meilleure façon de ne pas
gaspiller nos fruits et légumes c'est le
manger
[Musique]